it's the latest move in that can you top
this game that's being played by
airlines in the Middle East Emirates
Airline and Eddie hot Airways will
introduce full and closed private
bedrooms on flights
Eddie hots will include an attached
bathroom with a shower a lounge area and
a butler trained at London's Savoy Hotel
of course no word on how much all this
will cost you
Emirates already has what it calls
Suites on many of its carriers and these
cost about $26,000 for a round-trip
flight from Dubai to your 20 2026 grand
I would I would say this is just a sport
here Robert Kaplan with us formerly with
Goldman Sachs and now in Harvard bigoli
quickly here prices all of a sudden are
getting out of control again anything
airline prices just well the industry's
restructured where capacities gone out
and is finally after all these years
it's a good business it's a good visit
really is a good business and their
capacity constrained and they're doing
well I think prices are to the moon this
baggage yep there's a there's a new
company I'm not gonna give them a
shout-out but does actually options on
airline oh oh I can lock in your price